hello everyone the London chess classic
starts tomorrow and I thought it'd be
nice to check out a few more games
between alpha zero and stock fish now as
there are so many games released this
time it's not like they just release ten
games like the previous time it's not
all that easy to choose which game to
show and I always decide to choose the
one that well seemingly has the most
human element to it and I've seen as
some of you asked the seed a few games
that stock fish one and yes out of the
new match out of a thousand game stock
fish did win six games but none of them
are something really that I myself want
to see and this is not about who won the
match alpha zero will win every match
that's not the point the point is that
out of the those games that were played
we check out those that are well
seemingly creative seemingly you know
pleasant to the human eye and so on and
the there were a couple of games yes
there is the one game stock fish one I
believe in 22 moves but it's where they
play the position that usually would not
be played between the two of them so
this game is really features a brilliant
move the game is almost a hundred moves
long let's see no 90 moves but basically
only the 15 moves are important this is
also a game that first 12 moves are from
the book and only then they continue
playing their real moves so let's see
how it went and really it's it's it's
just an insane game it features
everything it has overprotection it has
two tongue it has the crazy tongue moves
so let's let's just see how alpha did
this d4 by alpha soul one of the games
that was not played with a reti opening
Knight to f6 we have d4 g6 Knight to c3
and Bishop to g7 so the Kings Indian
defense is on the board but like we said
the first full of moves are from the
book so we will mostly focus on the
moves that happen after those twelve
moves
we have d6 f3 at the semi variation of
the Kings Indian we have castles at
Bishop to e3 c5 Knight to e2 Knights the
c6 now d5 grabbing space in the center
Knight to e5 and now Knight to g3 we
have E six this is still all standard
theory Bishop to e2 we capture some d5c
captures and a six here we have Queen to
d2 and this is White's 12 to move and
now the game continues other book and
here we have b5 and there's still
nothing new this is all known and these
moves were played before by players from
I don't know 1600 rating to 220 is 25
2600 rating we have castles rook to e8
and now comes Bishop 286 and there is
only one game in the database that
contains this position it's better haba
versus marisco coups from 1995 where
Bishop 288 was played and black managed
to win this game but here a stock field
goes for a different line here a stock
fish immediately captures the Bishop
Bishop captures alpha captures the
bishop we have twin captures on h6 and
now we have this very nicely placed
Queen and h6 but it's not a standard
standard idea where where the White King
is on the Queen side you have an open h4
file or you've already pushed the h1 up
the board and you have a rook on h1 for
example here it will not be so easy for
white to attack so it's very interesting
how alpha decides to go about this stock
field goes Queen to e7 developing pieces
you will develop the bishop at some
point you want to connect rooks maybe
Queen to f8 to offer a queen trade or at
least force the White Queen out of this
very nice act of h6 square nice the D 1
by alpha alpha will go either 93 or
Knight f2 and from there maybe light
will go to g4 but mostly alpha wants to
at some point play f4 kick kick the
Black Knight away from me 5 so the knife
from g3 and this Knight from F 2 will
serve as protection to the e4 pawn queen
to f8 offering a queen trait and Queen
to d2 alpha declines the Queen trade
it's that's the general principle
interest when you control more space
which alpha does here you you wanna you
don't want to trade pieces we have h5
acquire questioning this
well weird position of the night mg3 if
black will be able to push in h4 and
then the night we'll have to go all the
way back to h1 so alpha prevents it h4
we've Bishop to d7 developing the Bishop
b4 is an idea in the future and this
Bishop will be coming to b5 offering a
trade of light square Bishop Knight to
f2 now the two knights from g3 and the
f2 are nicely controlling the e4 square
and f4 will be an idea in the future
because d4 pawn is not well protected we
have before rook to e1 and now comes
Bishop to b5 s planned offering an
exchange of light square bishop s-- and
now comes f4 by alpha so what do you do
here here a stop which goes back to d7
Knight to g4 seems playable and it seems
like a much more active square but after
Bishop captures Knight captures captures
and H captures you will get e 5 white
already grabbed so much space and will
have a much better position here
so after f4 we have night a 37 and now
comes the bishop to f3 now you can see
that Bishop Knight night and rook are
all protecting d4 pawn and everything is
well here alpha so conveniently avoided
the exchange of light square bishop but
it leaves stockfish with a very strong
light square bishop of its own Queen to
h6 not allowing any f5 ideas because now
the Queen from h6 is eyeing the Queen
and e2 and the Queen and e2 is
unprotected so rook to d1 developing the
the last rope that was undeveloped and
also protecting the Queen on d2 we have
rook a to b8 at some point stockfish is
also preparing to push on the Queen side
so you don't want to develop this rook
as well and get it off this bishops a
very nice x-ray envision Knight to h3
you wanna get this Knight to g5 when the
night comes to g5 you will at some point
if needed I will either be able to push
a 5 and recapture with the F pawn or
even push f5 because then the night will
be blocking the Queen's attack to the
Queen and d2 we have a 5 of course as
alpha is stronger in the center and on
the King side stockfish is a seeking
play on the Queen side
nice the g5 has claimed we have a for
continuing the game on the queenside
and here this is the moment this is the
moment where I chose that I will show
this game the if you put this position
well at least in the engine I have if
you ask the engine what do you want to
play here maybe maybe you can try it on
your own engine maybe you have a better
engine but here the ideas are something
like a three rook to see one night to h1
REE maneuvering with the night but here
the move Alfa plays a stock field does
not recommend and in fact it says that
it's not really a great move and it's
something that I could very very likely
imagine Michael Todd would play and here
alpha plays d5 so what's the idea here
if I've is a very well protected so
stockfish doesn't do well to too long on
it the D captures on e5 so the point is
captured and now comes alphas idea f5
and the night and g5 serves a very nice
purpose here the queen is now unable to
capture on d2 and one other thing most
likely this very odd-looking pawn
sacrifice comes because the move is a
stock which recommends a three rook to
see one and night to h1
I'm sure alpha agrees that those are
very nice moves but alpha is unable to
see how it can look for winning chances
from positions that arrives that arise
from these moves
so instead alpha creates unbalance in
the position he 5d captures and f5 so
what happens now of course you don't
want to capture this and all our knife
captures with an attack on the Queen and
those two Knights would be too powerful
here here we have Bishop to c4 putting
pressure on the d5 pawn but also
attacking the a to pawn but this is what
alpha had in mind of course everything
this is very well calculated b6 and what
happens now
alpha already calculated alpha already
sacrificed a pawn to create this well
very nice position and he offers another
point and stop which snatches it we have
Bishop captures here and now comes the
shock the c6 with a pin on this night
and also with an attack on the pawn on
a4 and what did alpha achieve here for
the 2 to pawn sacrifice well
for one it has a very strong past pawn
on d6 on the other hand the Queen and h6
is basically in a prison there's no way
for the Queen to get out this pawn is
controlling East 7 so you can't even
retreat with Queen to f8 and try to
activate the Queen that way you don't
want to capture here as well like we
said this Knight coming here would be a
disaster for black so for the price of
only two pawns are alpha bought this
beautiful position with a strong past
pawn on d6 and the black queen is now
out of the game and the problem is now
you can't protect the pawn on a4 by
playing a3 because now after pawn
captures the bishop is under attack
black cannot recapture although if black
could push a3 and create a very nice
past pawn of its own it would be
excellent
so Bishop to b3 protecting the pawn but
now comes look to a-1 going after this
past pawn you cannot go rogue to 8th the
bunch of controls a8 so here it's again
alpha created a position where it's hard
for black to even make a move and this
is unreal because like we said the first
12 moves were from the book and I
believe the first 16 moves have already
been played but it's amazing how alpha
finds these pawn sacrifices especially I
mean this could form for players who who
enjoy the Kings Indian this could give
them headaches you know when alpha shows
how to how to counter a a defense like
the Kings in it of course it is
impossible to emulate what alpha does in
any given position but I mean just the
idea such a creative idea I think it's
it's spectacular and here without the
possibility of playing an active move
you could go efore it's it's an active
move but you're just gonna be giving
back material for example Knight
captures Knight captures and Bishop
captures and now after Queen to g7 you
could go Bishop back here but still
black wouldn't really clean anything the
Queen would be able to reactivate itself
but you've given material back and
White's position is still better so
stockfish plays rook to f8 it wants to
bring this rook over to the a to this
route will stay here protect the f7 pawn
and wait wait to see what alpha had in
mind
Bishop captures on a 4 and a 4 alpha
to give back one pawn on the Queen side
we have Bishop captures rook captures
and now rook bt8 as planned
and now rope to a7 so stock gave back
one pawn D a pawn but now alphas
position is still getting better and
better the rope is already very nicely
placed on a7 and here stockfish decides
to go efore no more moves can be played
the stock fish has to make an active
move and this is the problem if alpha
captures the pawn here for example 9-3
captures on e4 and I've captures rook
captures rook captures Knight captures
the Queen's get exchanged two captures
captures rook to d8 defending the knight
and this is where it gets interesting
captures captures and the Knights to e4
and it here it seems like alpha has this
beautifully winning game with the threat
of rook captures and Knight to f6 check
picking up the rope but here black can
actually untangle wood rook to e8 and
here after rook captures rook captures
although white still has a very nice
pass pawn on d6 black will be able to
defend this create a passed pawn of its
own and it will be a very nice draw so
here alpha finds 'if I was a nice move
but here the move alpha plays is beyond
nice it's it's simply a masterpiece here
alpha plays rook the c7 I didn't ask you
to try and find this move maybe I should
have but I thought you know it'd be it
would be impossible so sorry if I doubt
it
doubted you but I didn't wanna I thought
it'd be better if I didn't waste time
because I didn't think anyone would find
such a move because now while the rook
is on c7 the same idea actually works
for the following reason here we have
looked to e5 Knight 3 captures on e4
Knight captures rook captures rook
captures Knight captures Queen captures
and Knight captures so the similar
exchange we already seen grew up to d8
defending the knight now we have pawn
captures pawn captures and Knight to e5
so here we have the exact same position
as we've already shown only the rook is
not an a7 the rook is on c7 and this is
the power of alphas rook to c7 move now
if black continues with the same idea
rook to e8
now you get Knight to g5
you've moved the night out of harm's way
and you're attacking tonight here rope
defense and now comes Knights to e6
attacking the rook rook to e8 attacks
the knight now comes Knight to f4 you
still have to defend the night so he
will either go rook here and lose the g6
pawn or you will go 95 and then after a
point comes to d7 white will White will
be winning here and you have to be very
careful if you play something like rook
to d8 then look to see a twins
immediately so the same idea cannot be
played this rook to e8 move here King to
f8 was played
now comes King to f1 so the the rook to
c7 move really really beautiful b3 by
stockfish and now King to e - we have
rook to e8 but now comes King to d3 no
longer the knight is pinned and here if
you try going back and playing the
passive position rook to the 8th then
you get King to c4 now White's King
becomes super active and it is enough to
win the game King e8 king is coming to
d5 after the rook moves king is coming
to e6 and now it's all over right if
they check King moves and now well
there's really not all that much you can
do you can even blunder blunder mating
one if you're not careful
so here stockfish decides that it's no
longer possible to play out a passive
defense it tries an active defense
knights the e5 with check we have king
to e3 and now Knight to f7 we have d7
attacking the rook rook to e6 and now
comes roof captures on c5 so you
stockfish could no longer protect
everything King to e7 attacking the pawn
but now comes hook to d5 and it seems
okay alpha is now up upon and it seems
that it will be very hard to protect
this pawn but not really there is no way
for her or stockfish to actually capture
it
the knight is controlling this square so
the rook can never attack the pawn from
here you can't go in 95 to attack the
pawn because the knight has to keep an
eye on the Queen Square and you can play
King D H to prepare night here - to win
the pawn because King d4 the king is now
coming up the board taking away d5
square from the night that point is
staying there so stockfish tries a
different idea rook to a6
again trying an active defense but now
Knights the c5 attacking the rook and
the b3 pawn rook to a1 and now rook to
d2 the b3 pawn will pour who will fall
eventually we have rocked the c1 and now
came to d4 improving the position before
snatching the b3 pawn king to d6 and
only now Knight captures on b3 so here
this is more 51 and alpha already has
two extra pawns and now this is enough
to win the game this is to two points up
in an endgame it doesn't matter who is
your opponent you will win that game
not of course there are positions where
you will not but this is not one of them
so this is what I thought it's a 90 move
long game but here are already that ePHI
- that rook to c7 moves that really
allow you to push to push for for more
than four more than a drone game which
is really really amazing in my opinion
but yeah like I said I wrote the c6 was
played here and then it's basically a a
matter of technique which alpha doesn't
lack Knight goes to d8 we have a nice to
see for King captures but now you will
grab the Kings iPhones as well 95 check
King moves Knight captures here and
there is no real way to defend the h5
point the rock is cutting the King off
from the F file the h4 the H bond will
fall doesn't really matter what black
does knight c6 check King moves rook
checks King moves rook checks King moves
now there are no more checks
rook to h1 now g3 defending the h4 point
now black will try attack the g3 pawn
but Knight checks King moves and now
Knight captures while defending the g3
pawn now alpha is up three points and
now it's merely a matter of technique
you could win this playing against
anyone so ok we can just play out the
game but there's there are many ways to
win there's there's there's no point in
in analyzing the game any further you're
up three pawns it's it's winning so
that's basically it a couple of more
moves were played and it was in this
position after alpha played King to d5
we should decided to resign the game I
always say stocks we decided to resign
the game but what actually happens here
is I don't think stockfish resigns I've
read somewhere that if - too much time
goes and buy too much time it's like
maybe I don't know a minute or something
without the stock Fischer making a move
then it's considered that it's game over
it's not like a minute but I don't know
the exact time so I don't think it
actually decides to resign but yeah
that's the game and I really do hope you
enjoyed it I mean that position I heard
that we mentioned sorry about that it's
only here it's only moved 26 where we've
already mentioned the stock which
considers all of these moves but office
simply says no I'm not interested in
that
v5 d captures f5 really really beautiful
and after Bishop c4 even d6 making
opening up this beautiful diagonal for
the light square bishop and it's it
entraps the black queen and stockfish is
forced to if it wants to release the
Queen to deteriorate the position give
back some material and then it basically
is lost in in over same game so this is
truly amazing that from from alphas
point of view the game was probably over
when it when it played a e5 sir I mean I
really really enjoyed this game and I
really hope you enjoyed it as well so
that's the game you know and I'm also
interested what do you think how is now
that we first a year ago we received 10
games played by alpha 0 now we received
200 games more and well sometimes in the
future maybe in 10 years we will have
computer strong enough at home to to run
alpha maybe at full capacity and how
will that how will that affect the
future of human play will it you know
become beautiful like this or will
humans not be able to emulate alpha
regardless of maybe even if alpha were
to teach children from a very young age
so regardless of that I mean good x
interests are to come it's not like
people people always say engines ruined
chess but maybe maybe self learning AI
engine
we'll fix Jess but yeah that's it for
this video I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Mark Graf young
Castle appall Cerreta James Jeffery and
Fernando establish the Oliviera for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos your
thing called for watching and I will see
you soon with some more alpha versus
doctors games and then we head off to
London chest classic thank you all and I
will see you soon